62 familles défavorisées
d'undre-et-loire vont pouvoir changer
d'air cet été grâce à l'association
vacances et famille depuis plus de 60
ans à la campagne les personnes exclues
en leur proposant de participer à un
projet de vacances et pour mener à bien
cette mission elle a également besoin de
bénévoles on en parle aujourd'hui avec
notre invité du jour
lou le forban bonjour bonjour vous êtes
donc animatrice réseau au sein de
l'antenne locale de l'association
vacances et familles je le disais vous
recherchez des bénévoles mais pour faire
quoi et bien pour aider les familles à
pouvoir partir en vacances en fait
l'idée c'est que les bénévoles
permettent de
permettre aux familles de voir partir en
vacances en levant les freins que les
familles expriment l'idée c'est que il
puisse vraiment favoriser les départs
augmenter les départs mais également
accueillir des familles en
Indre-et-Loire c'est aussi là qu'on a
besoin de bénévoles qu'est-ce que en
fait c'est ça le permet de l'accès aux
vacances c'est accompagner les familles
avant pendant et après donc l'avant
c'est tout lever les freins
tenir des permanences accompagner les
familles les écouter histoire qu'elles
partent les plus sereine possible et le
pendant c'est ce qu'on fait nous en
Indre-et-Loire mais également dans tout
le réseau vacances et famille c'est des
bénévoles qui attendent les familles à
cette technique cette année avec un
patient et ils accueillent les familles
les accompagnent tout au long du séjour
alors ça va se passer où est-ce qu'on va
dans quel secteur on va accueillir ces
familles qui vont venir passer leurs
vacances près de chez nous alors un
petit peu partout dans le département de
l'Indre-et-Loire puisque l'antenne elle
est le bureau est basée à tour mais
notre action elle est vraiment sur tout
le département donc on a beaucoup de
lieux d'accueil donc ils sont répartis
sur Ballan Miré mon Bason ça peut aller
jusqu'à chez Dini on en a également à
Amboise et à Chinon mais c'est quoi
c'est des campings ou c'est des lieux
qui appartiennent à l'association alors
on loue nous des campings au préalable
de la saison en fait pour préparer les
accueils on cherche les meilleurs
hébergements possibles qui vont plaire
le plus aux familles et l'idée c'est
vraiment de bah voilà donc on va
sélectionner tel camping on va réserver
sur plusieurs semaines et on va ensuite
le proposer les collègues dans les
autres départements et aussi les autres
bénévoles vont vendre un petit peu ces
campings là vos familles et ensuite on
voilà on organise ce qu'on appelle nous
l'accueil l'accueil de la saison alors
donc c'est famille elles arrivent en
Indre-et-Loire et là vous nous dites les
bénévoles ils font quoi concrètement
pour eux ils sont un peu les j'allais
dire les ambassadeurs du territoire
c'est ça alors les familles sont aussi
les meilleures ambassadrices de notre
action mais effectivement les bénévoles
sont un peu ambassadeurs globalement en
fait en pratique par exemple une famille
elle va venir une semaine au camping de
Ballan-Miré cet été une famille un des
principaux freins manifestés par les
familles ça va être le frein de la
mobilité puisqu'il y a beaucoup il y a
actuellement 6 familles sur 10 qu'on
accompagne qui sont pas véhiculés donc
c'est quand même un chiffre important et
les bénévoles ils vont les attendre à la
gare ils vont les atteindre à la gare
avec un panier d'accueil c'est les
familles elles ont le sentiment
extrêmement agréable d'être attendus
d'être accueillis les bénévoles ils vont
véhiculer la famille ils vont l'emmener
faire un plein course et ensuite ils
vont l'accueillir sur le camping parce
que les familles qu'on oriente on va
enfin qu'on accompagne pour les projets
de vacances certaines ne sont jamais
partis en vacances donc un camping ça
peut être une notion très vague et donc
là les bénévoles ils jouent un rôle
essentiel puisqu'elles accompagnent
cette famille elle la rassure aussi et
ça va être l'état des lieux d'entrée ça
va être présenté le camping comment
fonctionne un camping comment fonctionne
un blog sanitaire si l'hébergement ne
possède pas voilà de décennies de douche
c'est toutes ces questions là et les
bénévoles vont également faire deux
activités avec les familles et c'est
vraiment des activités familiales des
activités voilà qui vont plaire aux
enfants comme aux parents parce que
c'est aussi les vacances des parents
comme celle des enfants et l'idée c'est
vraiment voilà de que la famille elle
puisse être de passer les meilleures
vacances possible et qu'elle repartent
l'année qui ce qui suit qu'elle revienne
nouveau
comment fait-on pour candidater pour
vous venir en aide si on souhaite être
bénévole voilà pour faire la promotion
de notre territoire véhiculer ces
familles qui viennent en vacances chez
nous comment ça marche alors bah tout
bêtement nous on fait fonctionner les
réseaux de bénévolat dans France
Bénévolat tous bénévoles mais ça peut
aussi en allant voir sur notre site et
bah on nous appelle on nous dit bah
voilà j'aimerais bien être bénévole être
bénévole à vacances et famille c'est
vraiment entre guillemets un bénévolat
la carte il y a des bénévoles ils
peuvent faire du bénévolat une heure par
mois comme parfois 4 heures par semaine
ils font vraiment ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire c'est ça qui est important et
aussi sur l'accueil faut pas se dire que
un accueil de famille ça va être 7 jours
sur 7 pendant toute la semaine ça peut
vraiment exactement en fait ça se
coordonne avec les familles sur place ça
peut être trois jours dans la semaine
parfois il y a des familles qui vont
réclamer peut-être un peu plus mais il y
a toujours aussi une limite où les
familles partent individuellement en
vacances je le vois vous nous le
rappeler le site internet pour
candidater pour vous venir en aide c'est
ça W
3w@3w.vacances et famille.org voilà
merci beaucoup merci de vos explications